ANYWAY, WE HAVE THE FULL TAPE
COMING UP THE ARK I HAVE A
SPECIAL MESSAGE FOR JOYLESS AND
HER COLLEAGUES.
BUT FIRST, IN HIS WEEKEND
COGNITIVE STATE, JOE BIDEN MIGHT
NOT REALIZE IT BUT THE ENTIRE
BIDEN CIGNA KIT, FAMILY
SYNDICATE IS IN PRETTY DEEP
TROUBLE.
EACH WEEK, NEW INFORMATION IS
EMERGING FROM HUNTER'S LAPTOP
FROM HELL THAT CONNECTS JOE TO
HIS FAMILY SOLICIT BUSINESS
DEALINGS, AND TODAY COME A
BRAND-NEW BOMBSHELL REPORT FROM
FoxNews.com REVEALS THAT IN
2017, JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY WROTE A
COLLEGE RECOMMENDATION LETTER
FOR THE SON OF HUNTER'S CHINESE
BUSINESS ASSOCIATE, AND GUESS
WHAT, SEND IT DIRECTLY TO THE
PRESIDENT OF BROWN UNIVERSITY.
HUH.
ANYWAY, HOW COULD THIS POSSIBLY
BE?
REMEMBER ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
JOE OVER AND OVER AGAIN, JOE,
YOU SWORE, YOU PROMISED THAT YOU
NEVER ONCE DISCUSSED HUNTER'S
FOREIGN BUSINESS VENTURES.
YOU SAID IT AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER.
IF YOU FORGOT --
>> HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU EVER
SPOKEN TO YOUR SON ABOUT HIS
OVERSEAS BUSINESS DEALINGS?
>> I'VE NEVER SPOKEN TO HIM I
THOUGHT ABOUT OVERSEAS BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
I HAVE NEVER DISCUSSED WITH MY
SON OR MY BROTHER OR ANYONE ELSE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THEIR
BUSINESSES, PERIOD.
AND WHAT I WILL DO IS THE SAME
THING WE DID IN OUR
ADMINISTRATION, THERE WILL BE AN
ABSOLUTE WALL BETWEEN PERSONAL
AND PRIVATE AND THE GOVERNMENT.
>> DO YOU STAND BY YOUR
STATEMENT THAT YOU DID NOT
DISCUSS ANY OF YOUR SONS
OVERSEAS BUSINESS --
>> YES, I STAND BY THAT
STATEMENT.
>> Sean: JOE BIDEN NEVER ONCE
SPOKE OF HUNTER, ZERO EXPERIENCE
HUNTER ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALS.
HOW AND WHY DID HE END UP RIDING
A LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION TO
THE SON OF HUNTER'S CHINESE
BUSINESS PARTNER?
AND WHY WERE JOE AND HUNTER
PICTURES TOGETHER, LOOK AT THIS,
WITH HUNTER'S FAVORITE
KAZAKHSTAN OLIGARCH.
RIGHT IN THE PICTURE RIGHT
THERE.
AND WHY WERE THEY ALSO PICTURED
TOGETHER WITH HUNTER BIDEN'S
MEXICAN BUSINESS ASSOCIATE,
FOREIGN BUSINESS DEALINGS, RIGHT
THERE.
AND WHY DID THEY GO GOLFING WITH
HUNTER'S MAIN BUSINESS PARTNER,
DEVON ARCHER, WHO SERVED WITH
HUNTER ON THE BOARD OF BURISMA
HOLDINGS AND UKRAINE, THE
UKRAINIAN OIL AND GAS
CONGLOMERATE.
ARCHER, BY THE WAY COME HE WAS
JUST SENTENCED TO FEDERAL PRISON
FOR FRAUD, SO WHY WAS JOE BIDEN
MEETING WITH THESE PEOPLE, LYING
ABOUT IT?
DID HE OVER THEM A FAVOR?
AND WHY DID HE LIE ABOUT IT?
AND WHEN IS HE GOING TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT?
REALLY MAKES YOU WONDER JUST HOW
MANY FAVORS THE BIDENS OWED
SHADY FOREIGN NATIONAL,
KAZAKHSTAN, UKRAINE, RUSSIA, ALL
OVER THE WORLD, AFTER ALL,
HUNTER HAD ZERO RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE IN BUSINESS OR
PRIVATE EQUITY OR FOSSIL FUELS
OR ANY OF THESE FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
REALLY, THE BULK OF HUNTER'S
EXPERIENCE WAS IN, WELL, CRACK
COCAINE AND PROSTITUTES, YET
SKETCHY FOREIGN NATIONALS FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD ARE LINING UP
TO MAKE DEALS COME A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR DEALS WITH
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER, AND IN
SOME CASES, JUST WIRING HIM CASH
BY THE MILLIONS.
WHY DOESN'T THAT HAPPEN TO US?
ANYWAY, ASK YOURSELF, WHAT WERE
THEY GETTING IN RETURN OR
EXPECTING IN RETURN?
WELL, AN OBVIOUS CONCLUSION IS
THEY WERE GETTING A PIECE OF THE
BIG GUY HIMSELF.
REMEMBER, PREVIOUSLY, UNEARTHED
EMAIL FROM HUNTER'S LAPTOP
REVEALED AN INVESTMENT WITH A
MAJOR CHINESE ENERGY COMPANY
INCLUDING, "A 10% PAY OUT" FOR
"THE BIG GUY" TO BE HELD BY
HUNTER BIDEN.
NOW A GRAND JURY IN
HUNTER BIDEN'S INTERNATIONAL TAX
EVASION AND MONEY LAUNDERING
PROBE, THEY WANT CONFIRMATION
ABOUT WHO IS THIS BIG GUY,
ANYWAY?
WHO IS HE?
WE REALLY WANT TO KNOW, WHY WAS
HE GETTING PAID?
THAT BRINGS US BACK TO THE
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION THAT
JOE WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO WRITE
FOR HUNTER'S CHINESE BUSINESS
PARTNER, AB JEN PSAKI CAN
EXPLAIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WAS IT COMMON FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO DO FAVORS FOR
HUNTER BIDEN'S INTERNATIONAL
BUSINESS PARTNERS LIKE WRITING
COLLEGE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THEIR KIDS?
>> I HAVE SEEN THE REPORTS.
I HAVE NO CONFIRMATION OR
COMMENTS ON A REPORT ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT
WHEN HE WAS A PRIVATE CITIZEN
WROTE A COLLEGE RECOMMENDATION
LETTER FOR AN INDIVIDUAL.
>> A COLLEGE RECOMMENDATION
LETTER, THOUGH, FROM AT THE TIME
A FORMER VICE PRESIDENT WOULD BE
A BIG DEAL, SO DO WE KNOW WHAT
THE PRESIDENT MIGHT HAVE GOTTEN
IN RETURN FOR DOING A FAVOR LIKE
THAT?
>> AGAIN, I HAVE NO CONFIRMATION
OF ANY RECOMMENDATION LETTER THE
PRESIDENT WROTE WHEN HE WAS A
PRIVATE CITIZEN, BY THE WAY, NOT
SERVING IN PUBLIC OFFICE.
>> HE IS THE PRESIDENT NOW AND
YOU ARE HIS SPOKESPERSON.
>> CORRECT.
HE WAS NOT THE PRESIDENT AT THE
TIME OF THIS REPORT.
>> Sean: NOW MAYBE JAN WILL
CIRCLE BACK ON THAT ONE.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
JOE BIDEN DID NOT WRITE A LETTER
OF RECOMMENDATION FOR ANY OF THE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS, THOSE OF
YOU WATCHING THIS PROGRAM
TONIGHT, BUT HE TOOK TIME TO
WRITE ONE FOR A CHINESE FOREI